a wisecrack Jared here and today we're
talking about the ultimate one-hit
wonder one punch man one punch man is
unlike any anime you've ever seen for
one thing the show parodies just about
every trope in the genre
we might examine this in a future
episode so be on the lookout for that
today however we're going to look at
another way the show is unusual there's
pretty much no drama after you've seen
one or two episodes do you know how
practically all of them are going to end
with a big-ass punch and a yawn from the
titular one punch man so how does the
show remain so interesting well that's
where it gets pretty smart not only does
it provide a hilarious take on anime but
also a more subtle take on where
humanity is going as a civilization
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of one punch man as always
spoilers ahead our protagonist is
Saitama once a disillusioned young man
with a full head of hair searching for a
job in business and no businessman I'm
unemployed right now I'm looking for a
job he discovers a love for hero work
that lights a fire in his eyes but three
years later that reel is gone along with
that luscious hair while he claims to be
a hero for fun besides what doesn't seem
to be enjoying it much well now is Lam
that's because he's become so powerful
that he can defeat any enemy with a
single swing ever tried to play mortal
combat against your mom it's not fun
that's what it's like for Saitama every
time he fights what do you see what
happened it would be easy to conclude
from saitama's vacant expression and
resigned demeanor that this is a show
about boredom boredom is certainly a
prevalent theme but what the show really
focuses on is conflict specifically
imagining a world without it
in doing so it highlights the importance
of conflict not only to a fictional
story but to human experience the shows
abnormal story structure is key to
understanding its message conventional
narratives whether from a horror movie
sitcom or action flick are driven by
conflict in his book store
screenwriting guru Robert McKee explains
the music of story is conflict as long
as conflict is progressing and building
in the story it moves forward in time
without conflict the characters aren't
motivated to do anything thus in a
typical narrative there's an overarching
problem that gives the characters some
purpose find the bomb before it explodes
survive detention and press the girl
who's out of your league over the course
of the story the heroes of these tales
meet obstacles that force them to change
and grow each of these mini conflicts
drives the narrative forward toward the
climax of the story we can illustrate
this with countless examples but let's
go with a classic the original Star Wars
trilogy when we first meet Luke
Skywalker he's an ambitious but
inexperienced youth who dreams of
adventure
he faces constant challenges suggestive
obi-wan the loss of his hand finding out
the hot princess is really his sister
Leia as he overcomes these obstacles he
reaches greater heights as a character
all in preparation for his showdown with
Darth Vader this kind of development
doesn't happen in one punch man because
well Saitama is too damn strong
unlike Luke he decimates any conflict
with one swing of his fish worse he
knows he can't lose who doesn't in
benefit from the fear of defeat absent
any adversity he has nothing to strive
for so with the exception of a brief
flashback to his origin story he's
basically the same guy throughout the
series even saitama's training regimens
usually an opportunity to depict the
character's mental and physical
development is just the same thing every
day there's no progression 100 pushups
100 sit-ups and 100 squats
then a 10-kilometer run do it every
single day as superhero power sources go
it's pretty pedestrian which appears to
foreclose the possibility that he has
any secrets to reveal since Saitama is
immune to conflict the bulk of the
episodes don't really focus on him he's
either not present during most of the
big battles or he's relegated to a
passive observer he saved me it's pretty
amazing aren't you instead they focused
on the supporting characters
establishing their backstories and
placing them in challenging situations
jenos presents a classic character arc
the wandering warrior with a chip on his
shoulder convinces a reluctant teacher
to impart secrets of great power please
teach me the way to become strong like
you are also this warrior can tap his
inner beast mode and avenge passed in
justices I have an old enemy who must be
defeated at all cost so the battle is
not for me alone it is for my entire
hometown and for dr. casino as well
think Karate Kid or the bride in pay May
from Kill Bill or again Luke Skywalker
even the villains motivations are
developed like dr. Janus whose dismissal
by the scientific community compels him
to spend 50 grueling years trying to
unlock the key to humanity's evolution
it's all over there's no one in this
world who can stop my glorious creation
all for it to be undercut by one
lackluster punch I think I'm finished
battling with evolution saitama's
motivations in contrast are mundane he's
just doing this all for fun I'm just a
guy who's a hero for the fun of it
his powers don't spring from some
deep-seated pain in his past he just did
a bunch of exercise the ease from which
he's reached superhero status robs the
supporting characters of any meaning
they've derived from their struggles I
did not ask to study under you teased
your jokes and they get pretty pissed
off about it you say you do this fun
worse whenever these characters get any
kind of narrative traction my species
won the struggle for survival we possess
the ultimate and regenerative ability
Saitama is there to whip the carpet out
from under them born me out of my mind
just when vaccine man's rage is at its
peak Saitama floors him with one punch
and all the dramatic tension built up
over the last several minutes evaporates
the same thing happens with jenos in
Episode two as he fights mosquito girl
we learn about his character his desire
to minimize collateral damage
establishes him as a good guy when I
first spotted her I confirmed that there
were no living beings within 500 meters
in all directions he persevered
even when mosquito girl claims one of
his arms despite the admirable qualities
we've discovered in jenos mosquito girl
is too powerful for him but jenos has
one final move he plays the martyr and
prepares to self-destruct and save the
city I've let my guard down I have no
chance of winning all I can do is
self-destruct forgive me doctor we're
trained to recognize this as the
emotional climax of the episode but as
he's charging up for his big moment
sytem arrives and destroys the villain
with ease
rendering Genesis struggle irrelevant
every creative writing student learns
early in their education to avoid this
kind of narrative bailout it's called a
deus ex machina a plot device whereby a
character object or event swoops in to
solve a problem that had appeared
unsolvable for example in War of the
Worlds a seemingly unstoppable alien
race decimates the earth for the entire
film only to drop dead in mass at the
very end because they can't handle
Earth's bacteria Saitama is a human deus
ex machina when the situation is at its
most dire he just pops in to save the
day with his unbeatable punch over and
over again when a conflict fizzles out
like this we don't only lose the
narrative momentum
we're also deprived the opportunity for
catharsis catharsis is the emotional
release of repressed emotions and it's a
big part of how we relate to stories we
connect emotionally to narratives we
celebrate the hero's victories and
commiserate at their defeat
by the time we get to the climax of the
story we're set up for a big emotional
payoff did you tear up when you found
out quills mother called him her little
star-lord my little star guard how about
at the end of Toy Story 3 of course you
did you're not made of stone we respond
emotionally because we were late in some
way to the character or the predicament
they're in in his essay narrating pain
philosopher Richard Kearney discusses
how story permits us to repeat the past
forward through the actions and personas
of characters we can revisit our own
lives and past experiences we sympathize
for jenos whose sad story may remind us
of what it's like to lose a family
member he even took the lives of
everyone in my family our feelings of
encouragement from the Moomin Rider may
stem from our own experience trying to
measure up to someone that's bigger
smarter or stronger than us we don't
simply feel empathy for these characters
we're working out some of our own issues
too we see particularly good examples of
this in Japanese media in post-world War
2 Japan for instance the father of
Japanese professional wrestling a guy
named Ricky dozin would fight American
wrestler styled as cheaters and villains
watching Ricky dozens struggle persevere
and ultimately beat the American
fighters allowed the Japanese to release
some of the emotions associated with the
war to some extent kaiju movies such as
Godzilla which depicted mass devastation
akin to the havoc wreaked by the atomic
bomb serve the same function and it's
not just the Japanese thing following
9/11 American cinema produced numerous
films that tapped into the emotions
associated with terrorist attacks one
punch man is precisely the opposite
it's the anti catharsis sure it looks
like some of those Japanese kaiju movies
on the surface but since sites among can
destroy any enemy with minimal effort we
don't feel the drama of those threats in
the same way the Japanese film goers did
when they watch Godzilla stomping all
over Tokyo we just shrug it off like
Saitama does after destroying the meteor
stop worrying about it I think we kept
the damage to a minimum since no one
died we should just call it a win the
show has a lot of fun playing the role
of emotional spoiler it goes out of its
way to push our buttons crime enough or
a big release then depriving us of it we
root for the Moomin writer because he's
an earnest underdog clearly less
powerful than those big bad s-class
heroes
I mean he rides a bicycle for God's sake
the bicyclists for justice when he works
himself into a lather before a crowd of
cheering on lookers and attacks a
powerful foe despite the inevitability
of his failure we're supposed to root
for him too when the sea king beats him
down instead of some recognition of the
drama of the situation we get nice fight
man should be proud of yourself
totally anticlimactic of course all of
this is supposed to be funny and it is
but the show isn't just playing for
Laughs it's highlighting what's missing
in a life without conflict Japanese
theorist Masahiro mori oka has observed
the way our civilizations strive to
minimize pain and discomfort has
actually drained value from our lives by
and large life is easier than it's ever
been on the surface it may seem like our
ability to reduce pain is good because
it's enabled us to increase our pleasure
and comfort but to Morioka in doing so
we gradually lose the opportunity of
experiencing the joy of life that comes
from encountering an unwanted situation
and being forced to transform ourselves
to find a new way of thinking and being
the show provides a great illustration
of Morioka when Saitama recalls his
first battle against Rob lon take the
win means something to Sytsma because he
had to struggle to achieve it
flash-forward three years and we see
sytem uh considering some prepackaged
crab at the supermarket this
juxtaposition perfectly depicts how
Modern Life has managed to iron out any
hardships clearly sytem ou would prefer
to work for his seafood through the lens
of Morioka we see that sight to most
frustration stems not only from boredom
but from its inability to change and
progress through failure in pain this is
clear from the first episode when sight
smudge defeats back scene man and
experiences not triumph but frustration
not again oh I took was one punch
without any meaningful hardship his life
has become devoid of purpose just as a
story requires conflict to progress so
too does a human being the idea that
ease the tracks from life's value is
articulated again when site tomorrow
reacts to the Paradise errs manifesto we
will continue to write until food
clothing and shelter are provided free
of charge to those who do not work
sounds pretty boring for these villains
paradise means success with no effort
Saitama has this and he thinks it sucks
have become too strong
Morioka agrees writing that a
civilization without pain and suffering
seems to be the ideal of the human race
however I wonder if people might end up
losing sight of joy and forgetting the
meaning of life in a society pervaded by
pain reduction mechanisms and filled
with pleasure in the last episode of
season one it appears that Sytsma may
have finally met a genuine challenger an
enemy who can take a punch even multiple
punches consecutive normal punches but
it turns out that saitama's been holding
back the whole time in that case
use my own final move killer moves
serious series serious punch yup
life is still meaningless you're just
too strong and so in the dead fish stare
of Saitama perhaps we find a warning
don't get too comfortable be cruel for
your failures and embrace your pain and
suffering because without it life has no
meaning come on I'm back to one punch
again but hey if you need help coping
with the boredom brought about from our
comfort richworld checkout verb that's a
bee RV it's made by our friends over at
crunchyroll but it's more like the mega
service to rule them all you can watch
some full metal alchemist on crunchyroll
then hop on over to Funimation to check
out the new attack on Titan episodes and
maybe drop by see so for some Harmon
quests they even have some exclusive
episodes of bravest warriors another
show from the Creator for adventure time
but much weirder and darker so you
should definitely check it out Verve is
giving wisecrack fans 30 days free of
sweet HD ad free viewing so go to VR
video slash wisecrack or click the link
in the description for your free 30-day
Verve combo pack you can get it on your
desktop on their mobile app Roku
PlayStation and Xbox
thanks to Verve for sponsoring this
video particularly in these days of the
ad pocalypse Verve and sponsors like
them are really essential to helping
ensure that we can keep making videos so
the best way to support us is by
supporting them and we've got more great
stuff on the way including videos on ex
machina Logan Batman V Superman and The
Matrix Reloaded so be sure to click on
over to our channel page hit that
subscribe button and ring that Bell
thanks again for watching and for all
your support we couldn't do it without
y'all peace
[Music]
you